[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm Linc and I'm Rhett this is the
inaugural episode of our audio only
podcast there is no video being shot of
this to your disappointment I'm sure or
at least to our knowledge which is good
cuz I've got on flip-flops people give
me a lot of flack about this so this is
a new thing that we're very excited
about thank you for being here for this
our plans are to do this every week and
see where it goes I don't know is
history being made here I'm not gonna go
so far as I say though I mean
technically history is always being made
you alone in your room whimpering to
yourself or accidentally burping after a
meal is history being maybe the question
is is it notable history and I don't
want to make any sort of prediction as
to whether or not this will be notable
or memorable it is but it is for your
entertainment purposes but you know it's
also for our entertainment purposes one
of the things that we've been talking
about is how this is not what they mix
but this is gonna be a lot different
rhett and Link podcast this is this is
so we want to warn you right at the top
number one this show is not about us
right you see enough of us saying things
that we think and you know if you watch
good mythical morning on morning talk
show on YouTube our second channel rhett
and Link to you see us talk every single
weekday about something that we think
our perspective on something you can see
and hear a whole lot of us and this is
not just more of that type of thing
without a video component right this is
a conversation with another person of
course our guest this week is grace
Helbig she is not sitting here now with
us at this point in the process is just
the two of us kind of preparing you for
what this is this week and for weeks to
come
it's they're going to be conversations
with other youtubers friends of ours it
may branch out from there you know we
have a what we think is one of the
greatest jobs in the world we get to
make youtube videos full-time and there
are these other people who are doing the
same thing are things very much like
that and we just think this is a moment
in history that's pretty interesting and
we
and to know these people especially
since we moved out to Los Angeles the
world's pioneering this there's so many
people out here who are doing the same
thing that we're doing and we always
find it fascinating to just talk with
them talk with them about how they got
started doing this talk about talk with
them about who they are you know not the
the Daily Grace that you see every
single day on YouTube but who was grace
as a little girl and you know where she
grew up and what her relationships were
their parents were like and this in this
kind of thing what shaped her to become
the person that she is and we got to
assume that there's enough of you out
there who are interested in the people
that we're going to be talking with like
grace Helbig that you're gonna be
fascinated by this conversation the same
way that we are so that's the first
thing is that this show is not about us
it's about a conversation that we're
interesting interested in having with
someone else hopefully you'll be
interested in listening I think the
second point we want to make is that
this show in particular is not
necessarily family-friendly as we have
authentic discussions with other adults
there may be topics that come up that
aren't appropriate for kids so I know
that we've developed an audience out
there that with our family-friendly
content so we just wanted to say up
front that things may not go that way
you know I have conversations with my
wife and with my friends that I don't
have with my kids around because they're
kids and I think that we want to set up
this table literally we are at a round
table here we wouldn't where other
youtubers other guests can come on and
they can be themselves they can speak
authentically honestly give their story
in in the words that they want to use
and so we don't want them to censor
themselves we wanted them to be
themselves so first I think there will
be topics discussed that are or for
adults they're not for kids and there
was there may be language use that is
not appropriate for kids to hear so up
front we just wanted to say that may be
the case in general given the approach
of this show right and a little bit
about the name okay we put a lot of time
into this we actually put about five
minutes into it and ear biscuits is what
we came out with and we're just gonna go
into you're right we came out
yeah well I'm thinking I'm thinking it's
like we we put some dough into the oven
of our brain and we came out with ear
biscuits and they're a little bit
undercooked we acknowledge that but I
think the idea is that biscuits are
great everybody loves them they're warm
and what if there were a little biscuits
that you could put in your ear if your
ear were to eat as opposed to your mouth
that's kind of where I was going with
that now in England
I think biscuits are cookies they are
which is even better than actual biscuit
not according to me brother I mean if
you've ever been down south and going to
Bojangles and got a biscuit or if you've
got a grandma in the south who's made a
biscuit well I think the point is not a
cookie okay if it's a cookie or if it's
a bonafide biscuit if it's for your ear
you should love it the point is is that
biscuit means absolutely positive things
in every language yes every culture and
Swahili biscuit means good you don't
know what it means it probably doesn't
exist as we've already said on this
week's show
we've got grace Helbig looking forward
to that conversation honestly we've
already had the conversation yeah
hopefully you're looking forward to
Euler low alert you know for her from
her daily show on YouTube Daily Grace
she's also the 2013 Streamy Awards
audience choice Personality of the Year
winner and she's the co-producer and the
star of the upcoming movie Camp Takota a
scripted project with mamrie Hart and
Hannah Hart no relation I don't think
maybe we need to talk about that later
premiering on chill dot-com so let's get
into it our conversation with our friend
fellow youtuber amazingly hilarious
grace Helbig
[Music]
now grace we were trying to figure out
the first time that we met you oh and I
have a clue to this you do I do
okay this is gonna sound a little creepy
is this a game it sounds like they know
and I know I know when I first met you
guys okay well I want to tell you a
quick story and see if this all lines up
because the other day I logged into my
Facebook account which I do not do
because I really don't use my personal
Facebook account yeah anymore
because when I started you know my
facebook account it was like oh this is
a promotional thing I need to make as
many friends as possible right so when I
reached the friends limit which was
really the fan limit yeah at that point
it became useless to check this inbox
right but I was like I seen two remember
that I had personal interactions with
people other than you know friends on
Facebook like back 2008/2009 and this is
just weeks ago I start going back
through those and I found some very
interesting interactions with people
that I and for another time but then I
see grace Helbig yeah
and she says nice meeting you last night
something something something
nothing nothing inappropriate I'm like
what was I wouldn't happen what did they
say and I was like I just put it all
together we met you in the lobby at the
streamys and I lobby at the treatment oh
is that what it was no you know where we
met we met no it was the yeah it was the
streamys but it was the pre-party to the
street it was the night before the
streamys when they had that yeah in a
hotel lobby that like get together of
everyone and I was there with my friend
Michelle Michelle who you had the
channel yeah and Michelle met you guys
first show Vargas Vargas and then she
like introduced all of us in that night
and I was like those guys were so nice
she's like Southern Southern yeah that
is so crazy because I remember going to
that event I was there to do red carpet
interviews and I was flown out by My
Damn Channel from Brooklyn with Michelle
and we were just in that room thinking
oh my god these are real people from the
internet this is crazy
and we were very not educated in the
YouTube space at all and didn't really
in which is why you talked to us I was
like these guys are tall exactly I
thought about replying to your message
just a couple weeks ago oh my god that
was so nice meeting you too I would have
instantly been embarrassed and four
years later 2009 it was 2009 I believe
yeah Wow
so we go way back yeah yeah yeah now
that I realize how far we go back yeah
yeah that was a whole blur and then the
streamys happened the next day and that
was a fun time for all yeah I didn't go
well for anyone who doesn't know but
yeah it went so well that they didn't
have in the next year but yeah I had it
the next year and you won the whole
thing and now how it worked I did not
win the whole thing you won the streamys
I won the streamys yes I won the entire
streamys yeah so what oh what a weird
chain of events we're like wow we should
have replied a retz Facebook we could be
friends do we witness the whole thing
from the balcony that's subject we were
in the balcony of the streaming so times
have changed no he's talking about if
there's a couple months yeah the
takeaway here is always respond to your
social media yeah right that's crazy
yeah that was a that was my first time
around a lot of youtubers and I was
really star struck coming from New York
yeah let's go back all over you from I'm
originally from New Jersey Jersey yeah I
don't really have an accent at all so
people are always surprised did you ever
know I'm from South Jersey and in South
Jersey it's I guess more of a
Philadelphia and type of accent then the
Long Island like talk more let's go and
I when I went to college I went to
college in North Jersey and that's where
I was like oh this is where the
stereotype lives all the girls are
wearing leggings and Uggs and
having poof's which I adopted all of
those things and I was in college really
yeah I wore leggings and I still do and
he's a poof a hairstyle a poof is yeah
Snookie
you know Snookie oh yes as an icon in
this world it's when you take the front
of your hair and you like tease it up
high and then you wear the rest of your
hair down okay the last time you did
that probably when I Facebook message
you yeah I had I had a poof going for
years before Jersey Shore came out and
like really made it a jersey thing is
there a record of the poof on the
Internet oh yeah big-time
really yeah maybe you made videos with
my first My Damn Channel videos for two
years I've had the poof in them yeah not
on YouTube but on My Damn Channel calm
okay thing about podcast is that you
can't see the Wonder on your face yeah
the proof is a big deal for Jersey Girls
but yeah I'm from New Jersey and then
went to college in North Jersey and then
moved to Brooklyn right after with
Michelle Michelle and I were college
roommates okay yeah come but you know
your mom has it has an accent though no
but first of all big fan of your mom
when she made the knot that we we've met
her hung out her but when she made the
appearance on your channel for a couple
of episodes of Daily Grace she is a
sweetheart and she went to VidCon for
the first time this year and people were
walking up to her and like getting
photos with her and she felt like a
celebrity and had a really wonderful
time and she's very excitable so I was
worried that she was actually gonna
spontaneously combust with all the
excitement that's happening at VidCon
but yeah she was really sweet and now
every time I make a video with her she
has ideas for the video already like she
writes down ideas oh really because I
mean she's gonna start her own channel I
wish and I think the internet would love
that but she is technologically not
savvy enough if there's a kid in South
Jersey that wants to intern for my mom
and help her edit some videos
I'm sure she'd love it mom in turn mom
and the Craigslist ad will say super
intern she has good hair she's got very
thick hair there's a lot of bangs going
on she has big-time eighties bangs still
for years and years and years she did
the tease the bangs up and wear the
bangs down at the same time was very
very quaff very beautiful what does she
do
or did do or whatever for living yeah
she has worked for years as a teacher's
assistant in a special-needs classroom
so she has incredible patience and is
very very kind as a human being she is a
hero she definitely needs a couch it
makes no money whatever it's insane but
she puts up with so so much and she's
the sweetest woman okay so what was it
like growing up with the sweetest woman
in the world
well because she worked in the
special-needs classroom she didn't
really know how to turn it off so she
would kind of treat me and my brothers
like we were special so she would ask us
things like numerous times in a row
remind us of things like very very often
or like speak in a really high
sing-songy cadence so she was really
great but she's very much just so
over-the-top
sweet and patient but also incredibly
flighty she'll tell a story six times in
a row to you and you're like yeah you
told me well maybe that's maybe that's
just she's trying to drill it in yeah
repetition and teaching it's that thing
again exactly my mother-in-law was a
teacher's assistant for I guess it was
second grade she just retired but she
cannot get the like you said that
teachers cadence yeah and a volume yeah
whenever you talk to you like that yes
she talks and this is on the telephone
cuz we talked on the telephone
my mother Lana but when you I'm so happy
that you're here let's open the
Christmas presents before we eat food
tonight because that's when we'll see
her Christmas wait is she from Kinston
North Carolina Oh from North Carolina
I didn't want to I didn't want to really
turn on her accent but if you want me to
go but it's small you bring it down my
mom sometimes doesn't understand I think
she's got like voice of modulation
sometimes there she's not aware of the
volume at which she's speaking even in
like a colles she loves cold so much you
have coals in North Carolina just speak
loudly into coals
yeah she loves it like I can hear she'll
call me from Kohl's to just check in
[Laughter]
she's really bad at texting and anything
that's technologically related so were
you a performer in the family like was
it were they all like oh this is totally
expected that grace has gone on to this
career kind of and also know I have all
brothers so I'm the only girl and how
many brothers I have two brothers and
two stepbrothers and my older brother
and my older stepbrother were really
close and they would make all of these
like sketch comedy movies and videos
together and I would think that they
they were so funny and so hilarious and
them just off-the-cuff riffing with each
other was so hilarious so I always was
trying to make them laugh and yeah and
it wasn't until we took like a family
vacation to the Poconos and in the car I
started doing I think I was in fifth
grade and it's when South Park came out
and I started doing a Cartman
impersonation in the back of the car and
my older stepbrother Mike which sounded
like I wish it was something like that's
Kenny's cream cone really good and I
just did it once like by myself in the
back because we had a Jeep Cherokee and
my three brothers would sit in the
backseat and then I would sit all the
way and like the trunk area do like did
it into the corner to test it first okay
yeah this is this is good this is ready
to roll out
started laughing so hard and it was like
and then I just kept doing it again and
again and again I am my mother's
daughter
repetition yeah
and I I love that but then I went to
college to be a screenwriter to write
movies and it wasn't until I started
taking improv classes in New York City
that I started to get into the
Performing side of things so from the
cartman impression to the screenwriting
but connect the dots so I yeah how did
that happen firstly well you got out of
the Jeep in the Poconos had a lovely
family vacation really nice I think we
went snow tubing and my stepmom fell off
of her tube and sprained her ankle that
was you're not supposed to stand on it
she had a curb and it was like this tube
like luge type of thing and she fell out
of the tube and the walls of the snow
she like smashed she is not athletic by
any nature but so I decided I wanted to
go to college to do something creative
something in the communications field so
I was a communications major at first
and then I started getting into writing
and really liking writing where college
where I went to Ramapo College in North
Jersey yeah it's it's some of pó ram up
oh is that an Indian tribe yeah our amap
oh oh so it's not three words no it's
one word and I got a full scholarship
there it's the first college I applied
to and I was like okay I'm done great
I'm gonna go there and it's not that
it's a it's a good school it's not a
party school people leave on the
weekends all the time so like the social
side of the college was not huge but I
got into writing and I had a professor a
screenwriting professor named Roberto
marinus who great he was super great
what a name he sounds like like a
Hispanic superhero and that's called a
luchador yeah it sounds right yeah he he
kind of like took me under his wing and
became like a mentor for me and he and I
were writing scripts together really
your professor so he saw this potential
yeah oh she's good yeah he did no not
that okay didn't go that route all right
but he and I started writing some
scripts together and then he got a
Disney fellowship and moved out here and
well yeah and yeah he's doing it I don't
know what he's doing now
but he just got you here yeah he built
me up and then he got his scripts sold
to Disney and then he left okay but he
yeah I wanted to do some form of writing
and then Tina Fey became really big in
pop culture and I really idolized her
and wanted to do sketch comedy started a
sketch comedy television show at my
college and then started taking improv
classes my senior year of college in new
york's i interned like a crazy person
when i was in college because my college
was a 40-minute drive outside of New
York City so I had six internships while
I was in college because I was like
obsessed with working and with trying to
get involved in the entertainment
business in some way and so one summer I
lived in New York for three months while
I was interning and I wrote to a bunch
of Improv theaters because I wanted to
take a sketch writing class but I didn't
have the money to pay for a class so I
wanted to intern at the theaters and I
wrote to UCB I went to the magnetar to
the pit and UCB had a waiting list for
their internships and the pit was like
yeah come down on Friday so I interned
every Friday night at the people's
Improv Theater for a year and then they
had a not full level one improv class
and I last-minute decided to take it and
really really loved it and then went up
through all of their classes and got on
a house team there was performing every
week and it was really great
well it's interesting that I mean
obviously you're a performer but there's
I mean one of the things that we enjoy
about your videos is that it's you know
to call it a vlog is almost to sell it
short because it's it's always very
funny and it's a miss obviously there's
a writer's mindset that kind of comes
with it you can definitely see that
because you know I find interesting that
you did the impression
you got some attention and then that
kind of was like the beginning of like
oh okay I can you know I can do the
funny mm-hm
and then because we definitely can
relate to that you know getting a laugh
in class and I still think we're writing
on it that attention I mean I I
definitely feel like there's a big part
of the art career continues to be
propelled by wanting to be the center of
attention yeah
positive feedback really pushes you
because before every improv show I would
be so incredibly nervous that I'd be
like man this is the night that my
stomach explodes on stage like this is
gonna be the night I'm so nervous but I
did I did an improv show every single
weekend every single week I was equally
as nervous but as soon as it's done you
have this like euphoria of wonderful
positive energy and feedback and that's
what keeps you going to the next show
next week even though the moment or the
hours before of like sheer torture and
torment of it being so stressful
just immediately wash away as soon as
someone laughs at you in the audience
and gives you feedback yeah that's great
I think for us the euphoria is great so
I'm saying but at the same time I don't
know we're pretty we're so analytical
and I think we always skip to the Hulk
kind of beating ourselves up or oh I we
could have done that better or just kind
of we I want to make this better than
next time or this wasn't as good as I
wanted it to be kind of do you beat
yourself up did you even back then kind
of sometimes but the the wonderful thing
about having been trained in improv is
that you learn that everything's kind of
transient like the show doesn't exist
before it happens
and then it exists in this moment and
then it's gone the scenes you did are
gone all the jokes you made are gone so
you let it go and then you have to
create a brand new show next week and
that that philosophy and that format of
performing has really been so helpful
for Daily Grace because it's a video
every single day and sometimes yeah
they're not the best and I get bummed
out that they're not awesome every
single day but the idea of oh that goes
away and then there's another video
tomorrow
is something that drives it also is just
the constant like hamster wheel of
creating creative right yep I also I
don't know your story of how you guys
got started doing web video cuz you guys
have known each other since you were
babies right six years old yeah well we
came out of different wombs okay that's
good to know in different states and so
we're not twins or brothers you did know
that right I didn't have to like go back
that far I didn't have to clarify it
yeah I yeah and now if I'm your mom I'm
going to tell you all that again yeah so
yeah first grade is when we met okay and
did you look at each other in first
grade and be like that guy's cool were
you like that guys no it was that guy's
also in trouble right now literally we
were held in from recess for writing for
profanity on our desks and then we had
to color pictures of mythical beasts
which is why and now and that's where
the mythic really that's where the
mythical punishment well we we had to
color they're all you can I was at
recess we were inside coloring and so I
look up and there's the other tall
weird-looking dude coloring I'm gonna be
his friend I guess
but the only guy in here buddy my only
option but it was very quickly kind of
realizing that when we did something
funny whether it was individually or
together and you know the older we got
the more it became like okay let's I
guess we've become a comedy duo it was
getting that response which which
happened in like a live atmosphere in
front of a crowd for for a long time
like in college yeah did you do live
performance we college we did like we
were involved with a group in college
like that like a campus ministry that
met together every single week so we and
so we kind of turned that into like a
comedy club almost well there was an MC
right
oh and so we would be like okay and the
guy was you know he was funny and he was
like a junior in college and then so we
got him good with that guy and then
Rhett replaced him basically right and
so was there an
audience yeah there was like our
freshman year there was like 150 people
Wow my senior year there was like 1500
holy crap so it was like a big event and
like we started writing comedy songs and
making videos for it and then it even
after we graduated we stayed involved
like kind of going back and making
videos and then we started taking some
of those videos and putting them online
and this people started taking those
videos and putting them on YouTube and
it was just it kind of just created
itself I mean it was okay you see now
all of a sudden you've got you were
performing for a thousand people well
now a thousand people watch the video in
the first minute exactly you know and it
was okay this is this is a way to reach
an audience and then it begins to kind
of feel itself and then it just becomes
this I'm sure that it's pathological in
a lot of ways it's just what we do and
what you do on a daily basis now don't
draw her into this neuroses I'm gonna
confess to you that what I do and I have
told myself a million times that I'm
gonna quit doing this yes but what I do
every single morning is I roll over
uh-huh I get my phone I pick it up can I
go look at the comments on the latest
episode of good mythical morning oh and
I and that is not a healthy thing
obviously and we don't all you know let
her say that maybe maybe she's gonna be
like you do this help you do anything
like that that's sick
you I'm you are a horrible gross person
I yeah I wake up in the morning I check
I definitely check my social media I am
because at this point in my life there
are probably close to 2,000 Daily Grace
videos that live on the internet and it
used to check the comments every day all
day long and get really affected by them
but at this point I check them to make
sure that I didn't accidentally slip
something into the video that I wasn't
supposed to write or to make sure that
there wasn't a huge glitch and editing
that I didn't see because those things
will be pointed out right you'll see
your comment in the first 10 minutes
exactly I've put up videos that have
five minutes of
black space at the end without realizing
a huge fan of the strategy and then I
just have to go in and try and put
annotations over it and make it seem
like it was intentional but at this
point I am I read them
I'll go to check and I'll read a few of
them just to get the general vibe of how
people are feeling about it and then I
kind of walk away just to make sure that
I don't let myself go down the rabbit
hole of yeah getting too affected I like
to maintain like an overall Pleasant
vibe and make sure that that's okay and
then keep myself away from release
because you read a hundred comments that
are so complimentary and they're
wonderful and you read one that's like
you try too hard and you're like do I
try too hard just cage seven - okay
forget about it you're fine you're fine
four hours later like yeah but then at
the same time you have to go through
because for your comment episode you're
going through comments that's the time
you're reading them yeah that's the time
that I really comb through them and I
check them out and like get good and
drunk first or what sometimes um but
most of time not I just go through I
really look for when I'm looking through
comments especially from YouTube because
that's where the concentration of
comments lies I look for the most like
thumbs up ones I look I just kind of
like scroll through and I read them as
they go and they look for ones that are
thumbs up that I can I know I can make a
joke about or I can riff on or something
because Daily Grace isn't written every
day it's improvised and it's it's I make
like a mental outline of what I want to
talk about and how I want to talk about
things but I don't write anything down
unless it's a complicated video and I
need to know that I'm making certain
points at certain times for things or
especially when I need to make
announcements and I'm really horrible at
including all information and
announcements so you'd have to write
that down before but yeah I definitely
have an addiction to social media in
general I think as a millennial living
in this universe of
digital world I definitely wake up and
check my Instagram and check Twitter and
check YouTube one to me well also I let
my videos upload overnight so I wake up
and check it to make sure that it's one
has uploaded because there have been
numerous mornings that YouTube just like
now not today
and open like oh no okay now we upload
you don't come you don't confirm you
just you go to bed go to bed don't
happen maybe won't yeah I live my life
like a craps table everything is in
Campbell was spinning comfortable to
sleep on not good for the back well one
of the things too about you as a person
is I definitely people many people have
said this but we've always said this is
like I would not be surprised if all of
a sudden you know next week we found out
that grace just landed a part on you
know the sitcom that's about to come out
and you know so we definitely feel like
you could you're equipped to do that and
so there's this traditional media thing
that I know you know that you are still
involved in and still developing and
auditions and that kind of thing is from
knowing you but at the same time there's
this huge The Daily Grace and everything
that goes with that and you know
streaming personality of the year and
you know where are you at in terms of my
life what yeah what what you know where
you want to go and to tie that in with
just how interactive just that we're
talking about with these comments I
think one of the things that we think
sometimes is you know you just have this
really vocal group of people that almost
when you do something like Daily Grace
or good mythical morning it's like they
feel like you owe them something every
single day you start dealing with this
very vocal minority this like you guys
change this or you guys are doing this a
little bit different and now it sucks
yeah there's a weird social
responsibility now as a content creator
and I always try and put myself in the
viewers shoes I love Real Housewives as
a show on television and I look forward
to the Real Housewives of New Jersey at
8 p.m. on Sunday night and if I were to
go to Bravo and 8 p.m. at Sunday
and it wasn't there for some reason I
would feel let down so I understand the
sensation of providing content to
someone and non-verbally making an
agreement that you are going to continue
to do this especially with Daily Grace
when it's a known fact that it's five
days a week and it happens Monday
through Friday so I have I've created
this format and now I have to stick to
it but I am also now like I came from
traditional acting writing world and I
definitely want to make that part of my
reality now and we just got done
shooting camp Takota which was it's
gonna be a feature film which is amazing
and not something that I had anticipated
happening this year but came up as an
opportunity so I said yes because it
made sense for how I want things to
progress in the future I I want to do TV
I want to write a book I want to keep
doing movies I want to create more
webseries I want to kind of elevate the
grace helbig brand that is how it's
going so far and just um amplify it
amplifies the big term that everyone
seems to be using now I love it we
always call this podcast amplify we do
what is this podcast called by the way
is it not named yet no it is now ear
biscuits what do you think that's great
why would you say out of we just let you
know you go through a lot of names
confidently behind it's a yeah it's
delicious content for your ears now we
have a typo yeah no Daily Grace well I
want to go back when you came up with
that name you obviously came up with
this whole I'm gonna do this every day
why and what would the My Damn Channel
think so here's how I became a vlogger I
was performing at the people's Improv
Theater once a week and meanwhile as I
moved to Brooklyn with Michelle we start
making grace Michelle videos and as a
way to document two girls moving from
New Jersey to Brooklyn and trying to
kick start their careers in the
entertainment business
and it was also how we hung out at the
end of the night we had jobs and we'd
come home and have a glass of wine and
be like let's make a video together and
talk about our days and then one of us
would edit it because we both took
editing classes together and so it was a
fun hobby for us to use Final Cut and
through the people's Improv Theater
there was an audition that got sent out
to all the performers to be a narrator
on a web series called bedtime stories
which was for My Damn Channel comm and
it was a comedy series that took
children's like Grimm's fairy tales and
made them like super raunchy and like
over-the-top adults retellings of them
and I got cast as the narrator that were
wore pajamas and like really bubbly and
cute Lee's told these really awful awful
fairy tales like like give us a touch
point I I don't even remember at this
point but it was like Hansel and Gretel
go to the woods and they have sex and
how did you change it but so the CEO of
my name Channel after the webseries had
gone up found my grace Michele videos
and brought me in and wanted to
experiment when they were on YouTube
they were on YouTube yeah and they had
my team tone calm as their website and
they were on YouTube and they were doing
really well in the internet space they
had you suck at Photoshop they had wainy
days at horrible people
all of these web series that were really
groundbreaking at the time and so I was
so excited to be working with them I
David Wain and Kristen Schaal were like
comedians that I loved and they were all
in web series for My Damn Channel so
they wanted me to experiment with a
daily web show five days a week that
would be I would be the host of their
website I would direct people around
their website and say hey did you guys
see horrible people yesterday what you
think make sure you check out you suck
at Photoshop tomorrow and so it was more
informative and a way to communicate on
their website with their viewers rather
than just putting up all their stuff and
never talking okay so for three weeks
that happened and then it went pretty
well and I at the time had quit my day
job to wait tables in New York because I
wanted to pursue comedy as a career and
I wanted my days to be free for
auditions and that sort of thing
and eventually they I was able to quit
working at the restaurant to keep doing
Daily Grace full time for them and it
wasn't until Sarah Palin became big in
pop culture that vitam jennel asked me
if I could do an impression of her on
Daily Grace and at this point Daily
Grace only lived on mydamnchannel.com
you tube they had their other series on
YouTube but Daily Grace was specifically
for My Damn Channel and I did an
impersonation of Sarah Palin and went
really well
and so that kind of like lit the fire of
doing other comedy bits and
impersonations and characters on Daily
Grace and turning it into my own series
rather than it talking about the website
and then that was in 2008 that all that
happened and in 2010 after two years we
decided to move it over to YouTube
because it's very hard to get an
audience watched a league race for two
years mm-hmm on mydamnchannel.com
if you go to my time challenge com
archives there's like a thousand videos
that live there and there they were all
on my eyesight on my iMac and I edited
in Final Cut every day so there were
really really awful quality but I like
to think that the content was decent
quality was it so it wasn't much
different than what we would see now no
no it wasn't much different there was
just no structure every day was whatever
I wanted to talk about any character I
wanted to do I did commenting on
comments like very occasionally but it
wasn't a weekly thing so it did become a
little it was so fun but it was a little
stressful to wake up and have an
infinite possibility of ideas to make
for a video that day two years - you did
that before you put it on YouTube before
I put on and then they decided yeah a
guy named Jesse Cao came who is big in
the red vs. blue roosterteeth community
started working for mitem channel and he
really
an advocate of moving Daily Grace to
YouTube because that's where the
audience is they weren't getting the
numbers pushed to My Damn Channel comics
it's just so hard to get people to watch
videos on any other website so in 2010
he and I sat down and he was like let's
we need a structure for this if it's
going to go on YouTube I think that
would save your brain and I totally
agreed and we came up with the structure
and I got an actual camera and shot
I got a 7d I was so excited and then I
was like I don't know how they use this
things like all of my videos are kind of
out of focus and I'm like really like
framed awfully and yeah so we started
doing it on YouTube in 2010 and it's
it's grown into what it is now 2010
three more years so you three years I
think we started the five years you've
been doing this every day with yeah
ranks occasionally I've taken like a
week off maybe two or three times but
for the most part it's been every day
Wow
yeah yeah it's been crazy but it's also
at this point the same with like how the
euphoria of getting positive attention
is addictive it becomes like a workout
every day to make a Daily Grace it's
like okay I have I made this thing I
have to make my thing and then I'm done
for the day
I got to do my job for the day because
everyone always asks if I stockpile
videos and I shoot them all in one day
and sometimes I do if I know I'm
traveling and it's gonna be difficult to
shoot but most of the days I shoot the
day before and I edit that day and then
I put it up and it feels like exercise
and when it's done it's like ah what a
relief how do you think that affects
your you like your friendships your
relationships I had having to do that
every single day cos it's like alright
y'all this has been awesome but you know
I gotta make this video
yeah I mean the thing is I've made a lot
of friends in the YouTube space because
we all have a common understanding like
Hannah and mamrie are my two best
friends now because we have a very
common understanding of working and
getting I just shot
two videos with Hannah before I came
here and that was like last minute she's
like are you around you want to shoot
yeah okay we go over shoot for an hour
and then I leave and yeah it's a
respectful thing that everyone
understands but I really try and do I
try and balance life and work I like to
go out to eat I like to go out to drink
I like to be around people but then I
like to work by myself so I try and
maintain a balance some days it sucks
and some days it's awesome have you ever
had to do anything like we've we've got
a project coming up where we're gonna be
doing something where it's kind of like
it's a branded project but it's gonna be
like we're vlogging but we're gonna be
doing and recording it I think on Friday
next week and we're gonna have like a
client and you know an agency and all
these people in like like watching us
like gonna be right over and on the
other side of that well I'm sure yeah so
it's like an unedited like seven minute
piece oh wow that's like colors pieces
you decide you're making art I'm making
finger pieces but have you is it always
been that is it always you in a room you
know I mean obviously sometimes you have
guests we've had the privilege of being
a guest yeah my dog trying bite your
face but is there anybody on the other
side of the camera other than a maybe a
friend that sits in or do you not let
anybody do that at all uh yeah I'm kind
of a control freak in that way I shoot
them all by myself
I edit them by myself everything is is
me and I've thought about getting an
editor I've thought about getting a
camera person I've thought about doing
all of that stuff and eventually I might
at this point a with the schedule of how
I operate it would be really difficult
to bring someone else on because the
schedules really inconsistent and to
hand footage to an editor at 11 o'clock
at night and be like here have it done
now for tomorrow is
I think not respectful to another person
so at this point it's all me all the
time but now but I have worked on other
projects with clients I just launched
today a web series called Grace's faces
that's with Bobbie Brown the makeup
artist and it's a web series about
makeup it's not the R&B artists I know
trust me I've had numerous conversations
about what could have happened had it
been him but the problem is since
they're sponsoring you or however you
want to say it you can't play that card
you can't talk about the artist you know
I imagine that they're like rolling the
eyes big time yeah joke was awesome I
didn't see that coming right well the
thing about them is they're actually
really respectful of me maintaining my
voice and like authenticity of how I
would normally do things and those are
the kind of like brand deals and things
that I try and align myself with so they
didn't say no Bobby Brown the you know
the guy from new edition yeah they
haven't said it yet because I haven't
brought it up yet because you have taste
because you actually expect a brand okay
I apologize for the joke but but yeah
when I so I who did a bunch of Lowe's
commercials yeah it's very strange we
get very excited our house when we see
this it's the commercial where it's like
get lucky loves give me like it's still
twerking but it was kind of before and
then I catch on a fire and then yeah it
goes awry but I did those I love when
people leave me comments like you're the
girl from the Walmart commercial I
everyone thinks that like Lowe's
approached me as dailyGrace was like be
in our videos but I've been auditioning
for commercials in New York like three
years and then I finally booked a
commercial and it ended up being eight
commercials but dailyGrace almost didn't
keep me from getting that part because
they were worried about the brand of
dailyGrace interfering with the brand of
Lowe's and so but as soon as they
and the social media was really
responsive to it you know then they were
like yay great we good we took a risk
and it paid off
yeah so it's always really strange when
you have brands and other people because
you guys have done everything yourselves
for a really long time yeah and I mean
and we do you know having wives and
children that that is that definitely
impacts your schedule
yeah a bit I having one dog I'm like I'm
never having a child yeah you know I I
guess I can understand what you're
saying about it's it's hard to get
someone to help to maybe free you up
when you're doing you know you're doing
your show out of your house in your own
space in your own time for us we have to
protect our family times and then you
know we've built this space like
literally I don't know you knew this but
we built this building yeah I saw a
bunch of nails sticking out of the wall
everything we use Lowe's though oh thank
god you guys got a milos account yeah we
both have one oh and a business one
Eugene's got this podcast sponsored by
love so we can have people here who are
doing things to help us get things done
you know there's a there's a separation
it's a lot cleaner yeah yeah I wonder
what you're gonna do when cuz it's not
it's it's when I mean camp Takota
obviously the people behind that
understood your schedule I know you got
a shot over at like two weeks three
weeks and that was really wonderful to
be on send me like oh you you take that
footage and you give it to an editor Wow
what a concept
I don't take that home with me and edit
this scene that we just read it but they
understood that your daily grace yeah
and you've got to go make daily grace
but you know what if what if you do get
that sitcom or that major role in a
comedy movie and then they're like okay
oh no no no this leaving set every day
to do your thing like do you want to
edit her stuff is that what you get a
reply yeah I know I know I'm moving oh
great I just I need way more star wipes
and daily grace you're my guy
yeah that has been conversation and
has come up a few times because this
year has really been like kind of a
turning point for my career have been
really wonderful that yeah when that
time does come that's going to be a
serious thought my brain tends to work
and like that's not a problem right now
so I'm not gonna think about that but I
do
once one if things grow further I
definitely want to bring people on and
have people that can help alleviate some
of the stress so I can focus on just the
creative from time to time but yeah it's
it's taking the first step in finding
people I mean I'd love to have a fully
operational system of people that are
awesome and can help me make Daily Grace
and grace helping and whatever I do
awesome I don't know how to hire people
where do I find them which they suck
well you can get the Lowe's parking lot
isn't that bad
yeah I've seen those guys they're really
good at putting a roof in it's like you
were trying to trap but it's so what I
hear you saying is that there's no end
in sight to Daily Grace it's not like
okay well at some point when I'm the
next Tina Fey the inevitable then I'm
not going to be doing this daily anymore
I think I couldn't not do internet I
mean if anything were to happen it would
downsize the the amount of content would
become less but I couldn't just not make
content I I like making videos I like
posting instagrams I like tweeting I
like participating in the social media
environment and I even if I was so so
busy I think I'd wake up in the middle
of the night and be like I have to put
something on tape I just have to it's a
it's built into my system now but yeah I
think moving forward that's the goal
it's like build it out bring people on
that makes sense and and are cool and
and figure out what's the what feels
right moving forward yeah let's talk
about your experience working with us on
Christmas sweats
oh my gosh I was thinking about that on
my way over here about how fun it was
recording that song with you guys in
Hana and how exciting it was give us
your perspective my perspective was I
didn't know you guys very well I was so
excited that you asked me to collaborate
with you I was equally excited that
Hannah was on board too because I know
Hannah it's always more comfortable when
you're like I definitely know that
person I don't know those two guys yeah
I don't know what they didn't return my
facebook message through this project
yeah and I I love your comedy
sensibility about things being a little
absurd and a little nonsensical but
ultimately silly and fun and I loved it
and that the fact I got to wear
sweatpants was so so great I hate
wearing girl clothes
so getting doors up pants was like the
best costuming and wardrobe ever well we
had to have the conversation between the
two of us before you showed up I mean
there was no question we wanted you in
the video and everything but there was
the point where I was like well can she
sing yeah I know when you guys ask me
that no it's like oh no no not at all
was this did you because we sing this
we've heard the singing in the what we
did a little research did you see my
music well at the time I think what we
did is we went back and we saw you Daily
Grace is where are you saying and I was
like okay this is using the thing it's
not really same time oh yeah where I'm
like just talk singing yeah but see
that's me sincerely trying to say that's
funny
if that's all she could do that's
perfect right but if she can do more we
might insult her by asking her only to
do I know I did have that that like
sinking feeling on the way to your house
I was like we're doing a song wait oh no
Hannah can sing oh no am I supposed to
sing oh no I'm gonna lose this gig no
but it was great and it turned out so
great and the best part was that my
family loved it they thought it was so
fun it was on The Today Show or a Good
Morning America yeah and my parents were
Christmas morning yeah
my parents were like ecstatic about it
they were like because I was like this
is they're not gonna understand that
like my stepmom she's like I don't get
it but I really enjoyed it but they
loved it and that's I knew is is it good
yeah once my family sees see something
on Good Morning America or the Today
Show yeah it's validated there boys
finally done something right well you
know this is maybe breaking breaking
news here but we've got another idea for
this Christmas that we would like you to
be a part of yes I'm all right yeah I
still can't sing as long as that's okay
we can't we can't say what the idea you
know we don't actually know what it is
you guys this is how deals are made
they're made recorded on a podcast
responsibility to say yes you're saying
a couple of years later when we're deep
in litigation we'll be playing this
we're working up some sort of concept of
a sequel that's exciting you still have
those sweats did you wear them home I
have yeah I have the sweats Hannah
where's the sweats like personal related
we went somewhere recently and she was
just wearing the red sweatpants out and
I was like why your wing she's like I
don't give about anything right now yeah
they're so great they're in the back of
my closet with my koala onesie and my
ghillie suit so they're in good company
good yeah with your what suit ghillie
suit ghillie suit is a suit that looks
like moss or a tree that hunters wear to
blend into the environment I should have
known that duh it's a common culture
here no we surprised Hannah on her tour
for hello harto in Toronto memory and I
and mamrie bought us ghillie suits to
wear to surprise her you came out of
like a bush well we ran into a bowling
alley that she was in bowling wearing
ghillie suits and screaming Hannah Hart
smells like farts over and over again
and she thought that it was just like to
cry
see fans that were like coming to murder
and then we took the masks up and it was
great that's also documented yeah I have
a problem videoing things that I do with
us in your personal archive secure in a
Daily Grace yeah the security guards at
the bowling alleys they don't take no
here's the thing that happened they were
the elicits first we had ran it that was
the only they were the only people in
the bowling alley at the time and her
and her producer and shooter on the tour
they were bowling they're about to leave
and so we ran over from the hotel we
walked down the highway wearing ghillie
suits and we walked past people we had
to be like don't be afraid don't be
afraid we're just surprising a friend
we're girls were nice charming sweet
girls we're not doing something like
really crazy and we did that as we
walked into we had to walk through the
bowling alley bar and the bartenders are
just like what we're like don't worry
don't worry this all makes sense in like
ten minutes
yeah and then we surprised her and then
we all took shots and it was great a
great time yeah super fun then you shot
game or whatever shot get yeah exactly
no I don't hunt or skeet skeet skeet
shooting you don't no camo you don't
need a camo for skeet cos Skeeter
inanimate oh yeah true and it's probably
very uncomfortable well this has been a
great start this has been the first
podcast do you guys feel positive about
it was it a good experience yeah like we
buy great you did great house thank God
I did great
Rhett you leave a little to be desired
made a Bobby Brown joke great I said
wasn't a Whitney joke oh right it wasn't
you didn't bring her up that's right
until you guys had before the podcast
whatever happens don't bring up Whitney
is rule number one for your biscuits
well the other thing you're gonna do in
closing here is you're gonna be the
first to sign this this table or so oh
my goodness what uh this is kind of like
you know it's that's an expectation that
we're gonna have other guests it's not
an original idea but you know I it is an
idea if this podcast had any
Jules people don't attend this is a
beautiful beautiful 20 foot mahogany
table that I'm signing right it's really
gorgeous thanks for doing this thank you
guys for having me this is so exciting
[Music]
and there you have it the first-ever ear
biscuits episode is in the bag your
biscuits we put these in bags and then
people download them into their bag we
pour out our bag people download them
you're downloading this or you have
downloaded and you've listened to it it
was with grace Helbig yeah well if you
didn't realize that I don't know if they
needed a summary I wouldn't call that
it's not very good though
you know I think one of the things that
that I like about this link and I hope
that you like it too is I feel like I
sound like I'm about to fall asleep and
so maybe there's people out there who
have fallen asleep during this and now
they're just totally asleep
and now we're speaking to them in their
dreams and so you think about there's
somebody out there and they're dreaming
and they may be trying to fly yes just
can do it just jump up just jump off
without building if this is a dream you
won't die it's a myth that if you die in
your dream you die in real life this is
not a dream and you're actually on the
edge of a building listening to this
don't jump off a building for the record
but I think at the same time that it
might say a lot about this new venture
and internet tainment
if we're making people fall asleep maybe
it won't last very long yeah that's the
red flag and in most people's books
thanks for listening we will do this
next week so hopefully you will be here
to catch it in your bag
[Music]
[Music]